North Korean leader Kim Jong-un is a
reported to have arrived in the Russian
Border Town of Hassan is expected to
meet President Vladimir Putin in the
coming days well earlier North Korea's
workers Daily website showed pictures of
Kim boarding a train for Russia American
diplomats said last week that North
Korea is ready to supply Ammunition To
Russia for use in Ukraine
well over joins us live now from Moscow
what more do we know about the North
Korean Leader's latest whereabouts
well Kerry King John earn's train has
been spotted in Russia it is already in
Russia and is heading towards the Far
Eastern city of ladiverstock the North
Korean president is expected to meet
with President Putin as you said shortly
but he won't participate in the Eastern
economic Summit that is taking place
there right now according to kremlin's
spokesman demetrubiskov no press
conferences are going to follow the
meeting between the two presidents
between the Russian president and the
North Korean leader bisco has confirmed
that there will be one-on-one
communication and also there will be an
official dinner on behalf of Putin in
honor of Kim Jong-un so it's widely
believed that the two presidents will
discuss armed supplies from North Korea
to Russia which Russia is going to use
in its armed conflict with Ukraine the
United States of course has warned both
countries about all the possible
consequences saying that the U.S is
ready to impose with more sanctions of
Putin and Kim agree on the armed
supplies that according to the state
department something that is going to
hurt even more the Republic of North
Korea one of the poorest countries in
the world constantly teetering on the
brink of famine while Russia is going to
discuss with North Korea its withdrawal
from the U.N sanctions imposed on the
country which will open the door for an
even more supplies Russian supplies and
AIDS to the country
so you know what can we expect then from
President Putin in particular at the
Eastern economic forum
well Kremlin spokesman demetrubiskov
early announced that Russian President
Vladimir Putin would make many important
statements during the plenary session of
the Eastern economic Forum in La Diva
stock the main foreign guests at the
event will be the vice president of Laos
and he's expected to deliver his speech
as well so obviously we are following
all the developments there and are
waiting for everything uh what the
dignitaries have to say
okay you're a shopping live for us in
Moscow thank you